Victoria a medias de los sindicatos en
esta cuarta movilización en contra de la
Reforma de la jubilaciones del gobierno
de Manuel macron a medias Porque si bien
Hoy hubo más personas que el martes
pasado en toda Francia hubo menos que el
31 de enero que es el día que hasta
ahora es el que más reunió a ciudadanos
en contra de la Reforma de las
jubilaciones en París se batió un récord
93 mil personas según la policía y esto
seguramente Porque por eso se puso la
marcha un día sábado para que pudieran
manifestar aquellas personas que
trabajan en el sector privado pero
también aquellos para quienes en plena
crisis económica es muy difícil dejar de
trabajar un día justamente hoy vimos en
París familias con niños vimos muchos
estudiantes trabajadores activos pero
también abuelos que estaban aquí para
solidarizar con sus hijos y nietos para
que tengan ellos también las garantías
sociales de las que ellos han podido
disfrutar ahora se menciona una fecha la
del Siete de marzo si bien hay una
huelga anunciada para el próximo
dieciséis de febrero El Siete la fecha
que han puesto al menos los trabajadores
de ferrocarriles y de los transportes
metropolitanos de París para iniciar una
huelga reconducible según ellos es la
única manera de presionar verdaderamente
al gobierno de Manuel macron que hasta
ahora se mantiene sordo a las demandas
de la calle